WILL
FOR NOW, CONFLICT IN YOUR STERN
EUROPE IS CONTAINED FROM TWO
NATIONS RUSSIA AND UKRAINE BUT
WILL HAPPEN IF IT BLOWS OVER AND
BECOMES A GLOBAL WAR?
RUNNING US NOW, WE'LL THINK
ABOUT THIS A LOT.
SENIOR FELLOW AND RIGHTS GREAT
STUFF ABOUT CONFLICT LIKE THIS,
CUT SPIRAL OUT OF CONTROL.
IS THIS A LEGITIMATE WORRY?
>> I THINK VLADIMIR PUTIN WANT
US TO THINK IT IS BECAUSE IT'S
PART OF HIS STRATEGY OF
INTIMIDATING THE WEST,
THREATENING NUCLEAR WEAPONS OR
CHEMICAL WEAPONS.
MOST RECENTLY TODAY SAYING THEY
WILL ATTACK TRANSPORT OF WEAPONS
FROM POLAND TO UKRAINE.
THE RESPONSE OF THE WEST IS
SAYING NO, WE DON'T WANT ANY TO
FIGHT RUSSIA.
THAT WOULD BE WORLD WAR III.
PRESIDENT BIDEN SAID THAT TODAY
SIGNALING TO PUTIN WE ARE
DESPERATE TO AVOID ESCALATION
AND THIS IS CARRYING ON WAR OF
MURDER AND DESTRUCTION IN
UKRAINE.
>> IF WE ARE RATIONAL ACTORS,
IT'S WEAKNESS BUT YET YOU WANT
TO BE NATIONAL BECAUSE IF YOU
ARE A PERSON WHO CAN MAKE A
DECISION RESULTING IN BLOWING UP
THE WORLD, THAT'S A LOT TO THINK
ABOUT.
FOR EXAMPLE, AS WE LOOK AT
EUROPE, YOU HAVE RUSSIA AND THEY
GO AFTER ARTICLE FIVE BY NATO
NATIONS LET'S SAY THEY GO AFTER
POLAND AND FOLLOW A TRUCK AND
BLOW IT UP, ALL OF NATO,
SLOVAKIA, AND ACTIVISTS SO
INCOMES THE CZECH REPUBLIC,
HUNGARY, ALL OF THESE NATIONS
WILL ROLL IN.
UKRAINE, THEY ARE ALL FIGHTING
RUSSIA, ALL IF THEY HAVE IS
BELARUS, CORRECT?
>> CRACKS, NATO IS LARGE
ALLIANCES, 14 IN WHICH IS THE
MOST IMPORTANT AND A CLEAR
COMMITMENT AND AN ATTACK ON ONE
IS AN ATTACK ON ALL.
I DO NOT THINK HE'S GOING TO
ATTACK, HE'S STRUGGLING TO WIN
THE WAR AGAINST ISOLATED UKRAINE
WHICH IS NOT A MEMBER OF
UKRAINE.
PART OF THE REASON THIS IS
HAPPENED UKRAINE COULD JOIN IT
IT'S NEVER COMMON THROUGH.
YOU CAN JOIN BUT IT WOULD NEVER
SUIT YOU AND BETTIS WHY THE WAR
BEGAN, THERE WAS NO ARTICLE FIVE
PROTECTION, I THINK HE'S
BLUFFING, BLUFFING ABOUT NUCLEAR
WEAPONS AND CHEMICAL WEAPONS,
I'M SURE HE'S BLUFFING AND NATO
COUNTRIES, THE ENTIRETY OF THE
REST OF EUROPE AND THE UNITED
STATES SO WE KEEP FALLING FOR
THIS CONSISTENTLY, THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION IS SO WEEK, ALL
OF LAST YEAR SANCTIONS OFF NORD
STREAM TWO, THE PIPELINE
BYPASSED UKRAINE DELIVERIES
WHICH SHOULD BE STEPPING UP AND
THEY PLEDGED NOT TO GET INVOLVED
IN FIGHTING RUSSIA IF THERE WERE
AN INPATIENT.
FOR SIGNALS WEAKNESS THE REASON
PUTIN IS PROBABLY INFLATION,
PROFIT HE WOULD NOT HAVE TO
FIGHT.
>> ALL HE WOULD HAVE TO MIKE YOU
HAVE CHINA, THAT'S UP FOR
DEBATE.
WHAT HE WOULD HAVE HIS TAIWAN
AGAINST HIM, JAPAN, SOUTH KOREA,
NORTH KOREA WOULD COME IN ON
THEIR SIDE AND AS WE LOOK AROUND
THE WORLD, YOU LOOK AT THE
MIDDLE EAST, OKAY, THEY WOULD
HAVE SYRIA.
TURKEY, THEY ARE NOT SUPPOSED TO
BUT WHO KNOWS?
IN YEMEN PERHAPS AND MAYBE
PAKISTAN.
HOW MANY PEOPLE WANT TO BLOW UP
THEIR COUNTRY FOR RUSSIA?
THAT'S THE QUESTION.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT SOUTH AMERICA,
THEY HAVE VENEZUELA, GOOD LUCK
WITH THAT SO I THINK WE SHOULD
START ACTING LIKE A SUPERPOWER,
SUPERIOR COUNTRY AND NUCLEAR
WEAPONS.
HOW DOES THIS PLAY OUT?
IN SIX WEEKS, WHAT IS THE ROOT
OF THIS?
>> I'M SORRY TO SAY I FEAR
UKRAINIAN RESISTANCE WILL
ULTIMATELY BE CRUSHED BY RUSSIAN
BOMBARDMENT, PUTIN IS GOING TO
GRIND OUT FURTHER ADVANCEMENT
AND STILL A CHANCE IN CASE AND
I'M AFRAID UNLESS THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION CHANGES STRATEGY
STANDS UP TO PUTIN AND TRIES TO
BRING AN END TO THE WAR IT'S
GOING TO END IN BRUTAL VICTORY
BY RUSSIA WHICH WILL LEAVE PUTIN
ATTACKS AND OUR STRATEGY WILL
HAVE FAILED AND THAT'S WHAT I
FEEL, MAYBE LESS THAN SIX WEEKS.
>> I WISH YOU ARE RIGHT WITHOUT
RESULT, BUT SADLY I THINK YOU
ARE.
APPRECIATE IT.
ONE THING WE CAN AGREE O